tout de suite alexandra renard également
qui se trouve à l'assemblée nationale à
paris alexandra vous avez suivi
également sur place le discours de
volodymyr zelensky comment at il été
accueilli par les parlementaires
français
particulièrement est plein il s'est
rempli en quelques instants juste avant
l'intervention de volodymyr zelensky
vous le savez c'est une un discours qui
a été diffusée simultanément en
visioconférence devant le sénat et
devant l'assemblée nationale tous les
députés étaient présents sauf fabien
roussel qui avait aujourd'hui à aller à
des obsèques celles notamment de son
beau père il s'était porté donc absent
marine le pen qui elle ne devait pas
bien finalement elle est venue tous les
députés donc été présent avec beaucoup
beaucoup de journalistes présents
pendant ce discours est bien il ya eu
des premiers mots qui ont été prononcés
par le président de l'assemblée
nationale en disant que le moment était
particulièrement solennel que c'était la
toute première fois que la france
accueillait en son sein en somme ici qu
un président de pays en guerre un
président qui est en proie aux folies
meurtrières ensuite la parole a été
donnée au président ukrainien qui
étaient traduits simultanément dans
l'hémicycle par une voix féminine
française la voix de dieu du président
ukrainien et hématomes malheureusement
pas entendu depuis les hémicycles le
président ukrainien a dit voilà il est
difficile de croire qu en ukraine
aujourd'hui en europe en 2022 le monde
est à nouveau en train d'être détruit et
puis il a évoqué les énormes dégâts
qu'il y a à marioupol et à la suite de
tous les détails qu'il a évoquée et bien
il a demandé une minute de silence qui a
été respectée par tous les députés et
les sénateurs dans chaque district
chaque député s'est levé et puis il a
parlé à de l'armée russe qui ne
respectent aucun droit international at
il dit la revue l'armée russe cible à
l'aveuglé écoles les universités les
centres commerciaux il a ajouté que les
femmes étaient violées dans les
territoires occupés et que les
journalistes étaient particulièrement
ciblés il a dit comme vous l'avait déjà
dit en plateau il a insisté sur ces
valeurs que défend la france la liberté
à l'égalité et la fraternité
nous attendons de vous les français les
mêmes valeurs que vous aimiez la paix
avec la russie que vous nous défendiez
pour eux comme vous l'avait fait
précédemment pour unir l'europe le
demandons surtout at-il dit plus d'armes
des âmes offensif pour nous défendre des
achats russe est enfin il a insisté sur
le fait que les entreprises françaises
devaient désormais quitter le territoire
russe puisqu'elle participait au
sponsoring de la machine de guerre vous
alors globalement effectivement tous les
députés étaient particulièrement touchés
par ce discours nous avons eu quelques
réactions à l'issue de ce discours
notamment ceux celles du candidat
nicolas dupont aignan qui lui est un peu
plus nuancé il a dit oui c'est une
intervention est particulièrement
émouvante on ne peut pas le nier mais le
président ukrainien ne fait pas de
proposition de plan de paix il veut nous
entraîner dans la guerre et ce n est pas
ce que je veux ce que je veux moi pour
la france c'est la paix merci beaucoup
alexandra renard en direct de
l'assemblée nationale